you know how Christians had a Christmas
songs and Jewish people have Adam
Sandler we quanas don't have a song of
our own oh well I didn't really realize
that you were qu I'm half on my mother's
side that's why we celebrate
Christmas oh okay okay that's Quan and
Christmas together together that's a
Conjunction Function Kenan that's what
that is right there and I'm sick and
tired of all my white women asking me
about the meing of Quanza Jay how many
white women you got enough for e United
K Quanza okay
I got a lot I mean everybody can get I
don't just be sprinkling in the snow
okay understand understood like that all
right so I wrote a nice little Quanza
song for everybody you know what I mean
and I was wondering if I could debut it
on y'all show no no well thank you Kevin
I'mma do it anyway hit it
Avery you know you got a white man
playing a keyboard he's out bu though
Kevin he's out buying oh I'm sorry
we apologize sorry sir we didn't know
sorry just saying okay he's one of them
John bees got you got John be that's
what it
is people often ask me what does Quanza
mean well I just Googled it so now I
know
everything gather around why Quanza is a
hoood Das Shiki give GI and the
turn of fruit gra seven candles for
seven days these are the facts like the
Kara It's a manur for people who are
black look day one moja Unity of race
support the cause by giting me a Gucci
suitcase Gucci day to
self-determination is cooi
kagia damn it nothing rhymes with COI
K Quan Quan got a smile on my face
Quanza Quant where's my Gucci suitcase
ship
it those are days three and four 's also
the girl who gave me the Clapping
no4 day five reminds us of our
history speaking of History we're doing
this for free now a minute with
what
yeah caring for community on day six is
what we do
Kumba how about I sing and you don't
sing yeah no I know it's not always
about you hit it Quanza Kwanza is like
our Christmas we're on color people time
so we start on the 26 day late in my
need means keep the f
that is day
sevenes and Elf on the sh so how about
you wait wait a second that's just
ridiculous did you just did you just
come on my show and then make a short
joke on me well technically uh I made it
and he just hyped
it short joke okay oh Quan qu holiday
for every race Quanza
Quanza Mr
it's my
guci
suit
[Applause]
case no uh says here you just got served
by
uama oh man AMA again huh she be
tripping well you know what they say
hell have no wrath like AMA when child
support is not paid again Ama
why you still so
mad I told you I'm not the dad
Mor wait a second yes all right Jay
happy Quanza guys and guess what we'll
be right
back